because my cocaine you did the famous
acting masterclasses
yeah I did yeah in the 80s was no
conflated yeah must have been dat ya
know I remember we all promised eleven
watch them and did yeah I saw one did
you yeah and it gave me a big lesson in
movie acting big lesson what was it
about where to look when you are no
closer to you know yeah I do look at it
yeah yeah yeah because and the movies
because it's so high usually when you
engaged with someone you're looking from
eye to eye some reason or other and in
in the movies see you
you're either jerking around like that
and it's not really cool
[Laughter]
no you were so supposition behind you is
a camera right yeah I'm talking to you
yep so if I'm naturally talking to you
by two eyes are on you here and we're
talking in a camera I move over to there
and my other eye is in the camera but
I'm looking at you
[Music]
why have you don't blink unless you know
you got something in your eye yeah I
don't have to blink Adelina Dietrich
told me that Rick told me that yeah I
was at a birthday party for Liza
Minnelli and her godmother was Marlena
Dietrich and then she saw me and I was
just sort of famous as Elfi or something
you know no and she knew who I was and
she said to me she said you're supposed
to be a movie star
why are you dressed so scruffy Lee and
she started giving me a Bulacan about
dressing yeah and there was a buffet and
she said there's a buffet let's have
dinner so I said okay alright okay I
said coming in we're going to she said
no you choose I said what do you want to
see whatever you have I'll have it and
then I sat down and she said and another
thing you're using the wrong eyes and
then she told me that story
hmm it's amazing and then someone else
had never blink people don't like that
when you blink no never but you know
there's a reason okay you can you can
make comments yeah I talk to you without
blinking the entire time you didn't
blink once and I just assumed you may
have had a glass eye
[Music]